un geste affirmé un savoir faire
ancestral
anita loisel travaillent la terre de ses
mains avec une patience absolue une
aventure commencée il ya vingt ans dans
un atelier de ben la céramique les
découvertes en 1994 et c'est devenu une
passion
de jour en jour je sais c'était vraiment
le bonheur
il ya une liberté de modelage qui est
exceptionnel pour la terre vous faites
ce que vous voulez avec la terre il ya
très peu de matériaux qui lui qui
rivalise avec une passion devenue un
métier en 2004 à la suite d'une
formation de six mois
anita travaille désormais à la mjc des
clayes-sous-bois comme professeur elles
vont également ses oeuvres une dizaine
par an
sa signature des corps et des visages
des structures est un moyen de traduire
les thèmes qui lui sont chers
c'est souvent les populations spoliées
de leurs territoires
je pense entre autres à la masoni la
perte d'identité la condition de la
femme
ça m'émeut profondément et c'est vrai
que quand je travaille je pense souvent
à ça et je pense que c'est maintenant
avec le temps je pense que c'est pour ça
que je morcelle mes personnages que
toujours ils sont fracturées après le
modelage la sculpture est mise au four à
900 degrés pour la solidifier un passage
toujours délicat il faut être humble je
dirai pas ce que vous faites une
sculpture pour la mettez au four mais
c'est pas toujours le résultat n'est pas
toujours celui que vous escomptez donc
il faut vous réapproprier la sculpture
l'objet une fois cuisse
du 1er au 3 avril dans le cadre des
journées européennes des métiers d'art
elle exposera à l'espace philippe noiret
des clayes-sous-bois l'occasion de faire
découvrir son métier au public dans les
yvelines plus de 150 rencontres et
événements sont prévus